hey guys listen I wanted to cover this
topic I get people that say oh I'm
skinny so I can eat whatever I want
right let's just talk about that
assuming that if you don't have any fat
extra fat on your body you're going to
be healthy is a mistake because if you
ever check a blood and someone who eats
junk food and yet they're skinny you're
going to find there are usually a
pre-diabetic they have a lot of
cholesterol issues too got high a1c
which is an indicator of diabetes and so
let's just show you what really happens
what happens is they have a very very
high metabolic rate okay so when the
sugar goes in the blood insulin is
kicked in there so the insulin is then
stored as sugar and the excess is stored
as fat and cholesterol so what happens
is that because your metabolism is so
fast they're able to dissolve this fat
as they're consuming it and is they're
converting it but they're not able to
break down the cholesterol because your
body can't use cholesterol as fuel and
that's why if you ever check someone
who's skinny wheats like jug their bad
cholesterol is just their profiles of
triglycerides are like off the chart so
it catches up with them when they get
diabetes but that's what happens so the
metabolism really kind of makes them
appear to be healthy when they're really
not
and there's one study I want to put down
below which is fascinating because it
talked about longevity and so this is
what it said this is the summary of it
an overweight person and an obese person
class one actually live a little bit
longer than a thinner person okay I know
that's hard to believe but probably the
good thing about gaining weight is that
it wakes you up and it gets you to
change your diet even for myself I was
very very thin all the way up going
through my 20s and I never had never
motivated me to make a change until my
my late 20s and so people a lot of times
they don't change their ways until
they're either have a problem but the
biggest motive
is when your gut starts getting big and
you can't get in your clothes that's a
huge motivator so that's one good thing
but it's interesting that overweight
people and obese type one live a little
bit longer like six percent more than
ten people interesting put your comments
down below
hi guys listen I created an evaluation
quiz it is quite long it's 104 questions
but it's very thorough click the link
below and take it it will help you to
find out what's really behind all your
symptoms